[Musik]
SALLY: Hallo. Herzlich willkommen zu Sallys Welt.
Heute gibt es Pasta Chips.
Aus übrig gebliebenen Nudeln könnt ihr nämlich ganz toll eine
Resteverwertung machen oder für dieses Rezept extra Nudeln abkochen.
Ich habe hier also kalte Nudeln;
die werden gleich mariniert, dann im Ofen gegart
und dann hat man einen richtig tollen, leckeren Snack.
Der ist im Prinzip wie Chips.
Ich habe mir jetzt drei Geschmacksrichtungen dazu überlegt.
Ich habe den Pasta-Trend auf TikTok entdeckt und habe mir gedacht:
Komm, wir machen da jetzt direkt drei verschiedene Versionen draus.
Ich habe mir sogar sechs Rezepte überlegt,
aber komm, wir wollen es mal nicht übertreiben.
Wir machen drei:
Ich habe einmal die Version Cheese Oregano, eine Döner-Version
und eine Honey Mustard - so ein bisschen wie diese Snyder's Pretzels.
Da gibt es ja auch diese Geschmacksrichtung.
Ich habe mir noch drei weitere überlegt.
Also wenn ihr wollt, dass ich die drei weiteren auch noch zubereite,
dann schreibt es einfach gern in die Kommentare.
Ansonsten starte ich jetzt einmal mit Cheese Oregano.
Ich hab jetzt hier einfach immer 225 g rohe Nudeln abgekocht,
abkühlen lassen und das sind sie jetzt praktisch.
Und wie gesagt, ihr könnt auch einfach die Nudelreste dafür verwenden.
Die sind jetzt schon kalt.
Hier sind die Zutaten:
Ich verwende dafür 5 EL Olivenöl, 100 g Parmesan (fein gerieben),
Salz und Pfeffer und 1 EL Oregano.
Die Zubereitung ist ganz easy:
Einfach kurz alles verrühren,
d.h., alles schön mit dem Öl bedecken,
Gewürze rein, verrühren und ab aufs Blech.
[Musik]
Das riecht jetzt schon wahnsinnig gut.
Dann kommen sie hier direkt aufs Blech.
Ich werde sie aber gleich alle drei zusammen backen.
Den Ofen habe ich schon auf 180°C Heißluft vorgeheizt.
Dann kann ich nämlich drei Bleche gleichzeitig backen.
Hier jetzt einfach darauf achten,
dass alle so ein bisschen einzeln da liegen,
damit sie auch rundherum schön kross werden.
[Musik]
„Und Sally, was hast du heute so gemacht?"
„Du, ich habe Nudeln auf dem Blech sortiert."
„Echt? Den ganzen Tag?"
„Ja, den ganzen Tag." [Lacht]
[Musik]
Version 1 ist fertig.
Jetzt kommt die zweite, nämlich die Döner-Version.
Für die Döner-Version verwende ich 5 EL Chili-Olivenöl.
Dann hab ich hier noch die Gewürze:
Salz und Pfeffer, etwas Kreuzkümmel, Bergbohnenkraut und Paprika.
[Musik]
Die Chili-Version am besten mit Löffeln verrühren,
denn sonst verfärben sich eure Hände und Nägel
und vor allem ist Chili an den Fingern immer gefährlich,
weil man sich danach auch nach dem Händewaschen oft ins Auge fasst
und dann brennt alles.
Ja, das riecht auch gut.
[Musik]
Falls ihr es nicht ganz so scharf haben wollt,
könnt ihr natürlich auch nur 1 EL Chili-Öl nehmen
oder eben Chili-Pulver und den Rest mit normalem Olivenöl auffüllen.
Aber ich dachte mir so:
„Döner, einmal mit alles und scharf"
- wird jetzt extra scharf, egal!
Ich glaube, ich rühre sie einfach gleich im Ofen,
wenn sie so ein bisschen gebacken sind, einmal durch.
Ich sortiere jetzt nicht alle Nudeln.
Nein, auch eine Sally macht das nicht!
Kommen wir zur dritten Geschmacksrichtung, nämlich Honey Mustard.
Für die Honey-Mustard-Mischung nehme ich 5 EL Olivenöl, 2 EL Senf,
2 EL Honig, 1 EL Essig, Salz, Pfeffer, etwas Kurkuma und Paprikapulver.
[Musik]
Bei dieser Version verrühre ich kurz alle Zutaten zu einer Marinade
und vermenge sie dann mit den Nudeln.
[Musik]
Ich bin dem Sortierwahn verfallen.
Habe ich dir mal das mit den Nudelwitzen erzählt,
die mal in der Stadt als Plakataktion waren?
[Josh verneint]
Da stand dann:
„Ich bin dir so verfalle. Willst du mit mir Penne?"
Lauter solcher Nudelnamen.
Ich weiß jetzt nicht, ob es ein Restaurant in Karlsruhe
oder ob es irgenwie so eine Barilla-Aktion oder so war.
Keine Ahnung, aber es war lustig.
[Musik]
[Uhr]
[Backgeräusche]
[Musik]
Jetzt sind die Pasta-Chips fertig.
Ich habe jetzt hier noch für die Cheese-Oregano-Version
ein Satsebeli zubereitet.
Das ist einfach so eine Tomatensauce mit ein bisschen Gewürzen.
Hier für den Kebab Style eine, klar, Dönersauce - eine Joghurtsauce.
Und für Honey Mustard habe ich hier die Cheeseburger-Sauce
bzw. die Big-Mac-Sauce. Die findet ihr auf meinem Kanal.
Ich schreibe euch alle Rezepte direkt in die App und in den Blog.
Jetzt Darf der Josh probieren.
JOSH: Ich bin sehr gespannt.
wenn einem so etwas erwartet,
wenn man aus dem Urlaub zurückkommt.
Spaß. Ich habe heute Morgen nur vergessen meine Sonnenbrille abzusetzen.
SALLY: Komm, wir probieren.
JOSH: Ich bin mega, mega gespannt.
Also es hat vorhin schon so krass gut gerochen,
[Sehr krosse Geräusche]
SALLY: Aber ich weiß gar nicht, was ich als Erstes probieren will.
JOSH: Ich glaube Döner Style, muss ich ehrlich sagen.
SALLY: Boah, sind sie crunchy!
JOSH: Wow. Oha!
Schon scharf, schon scharf!
SALLY: Das war einmal Döner mit alles und scharf.
JOSH: Das habe ich, wenn der Dönermann viel scharf reinmacht.
Lecker, mega lecker!
Auf die Burgersauce bin ich echt mega gespannt.
SALLY: Oh, die sind so leicht süßlich.
BEIDE:
Hm! Mmh! Mmh!
JOSH: Oh, okay, ich hole mir noch einen.
SALLY: Oah, mit der Sauce.
Vergesst Chips. Vergesst Popcorn.
Pasta!
JOSH: Okay!
SALLY: Hammer!
JOSH: Das ist das neue Ding!
SALLY: Sarah, komm!
SARAH: Ich habe einen Topf in der Hand.
SALLY: Egal, sann sieht man, dass was schaffst.
JOSH: Mmh! Oah! Oah!
SARAH: Welche ist das Beste?
SALLY: Aber die mit der Sauce ist auch hammer.
JOSH: Ich empfehle dir - warte kurz:
Eins, zwei, drei. Dann steigerst du dich.
SALLY: Aber da ist es vielleicht dann so durch die Chilischote…
SARAH: Ja.
JOSH: Ach so. Oh, das ist smart.
SALLY: Weil nach der Chilischote…
SARAH: Ist das Döner?
SALLY: Nein, Honey Mustard. Das ist Döner.
SARAH: [Lacht] Oh, schneiden wir raus.
Ist das Honey Mustard?
JOSH: Das lassen wir drin.
Nein, das sind Nudeln.
SALLY: Oah!
JOSH: Oah, die sind unnormal lecker!
SALLY: Hammer.
JOSH: Man muss sagen, der Käse macht es so ein bisschen herzhaft.
SALLY: Der Käse ist der Hammer.
JOSH: Oah! Wie kross die auch geworden sind.
SALLY: Aber auch Döner hier.
SARAH: Werden sie auch in meinem Backofen so kross? [Sally bejaht]
Wie lange waren sie da drin?
JOSH: 02 Minuten?
SARAH: Peace out! 20?
SALLY: Die mit Parmesan waren 5 Minuten länger, aber so 20 Minuten… Hammer!
JOSH: Die Döner könnten so einen Hauch knuspriger sein.
SALLY: Ja, die hätte man länger lassen müssen.
Ich war von der Farbe irritiert.
JOSH: Ja, aber auch so voll lecker!
SALLY: Diese hier… Wahnsinn! Wow!
JOSH: Alle der Hammer!
Und auch alle drei Dips sind alle übelst lecker.
Die Burgersauce ist gut, gell?
SALLY: [Stimmt zu] Big-Macs-Sauce.
Probiert es gern aus.
Also ich hatte noch Garam-Masala-Style.
Was ist mir noch eingefallen?
Garam Masala…
SARAH: Barbecue
SALLY: Barbecue könnte man noch machen.
Also wir haben echt schon noch ein paar Ideen, die wir machen könnten.
Vinegar?
Ja genau, Salt and Vinegar.
JOSH: Lahmacun-Style.
SALLY: Oah, Lahmacun-Style… !
Gut, das ist ja fast…
JOSH: Fast Döner.
Ist das zulässig, zu variieren?
Ja, stell mal… Warum hast du seit einer halben Stunde den Topf in der Hand?
Okay. Ich glaube, ich probiere mal..
Ich probiere mal favourite Sauce
mit favourite Snack. [Sally und Sarah stimmen zu]
SALLY: Aber nein, die passt besser zu dem.
SARAH: Oh, jetzt habe ich gekleckert.
SALLY: Ich finde, Honey Mustard war da besser.
SARAH: Ich habe da reingekleckert.
JOSH: Tövbe, tövbe! (Schäm dich!)
Auch voll gut, gell?
Ich probier mal…
SALLY: Wir haben… Merkt man, dass wir Hunger haben?
[Sarah und Josh bejahen)
Nein, das merkt man nicht…
JOSH: Das ist ein Fehler, sowas zu probieren,
wenn wir noch kein Mittagessen hatten.
SALLY: Wir hatten auch kein Früchstück.
JOSH: Stimmt, das auch nicht, ja…
SALLY: Okay. Also wir probieren es mal weiter durch.
Schreibt mir gern eure Lieblingsgeschmacksrichtung in die Kommentare
und auch gern, falls ihr noch weitere Ideen habt.
Dann mache ich die gern beim nächsten Mal, falls ihr sie sehen wollt.
Also macht's gut. Bis zum nächsten Mal.
Tschüss!
JOSH: Tschüss! Und kommentiert mal eure Lieblings-Pastasorte.
SARAH: Du Influencer! [Lacht]
JOSH: Kann man doch mal fragen, was die Lieblings-Pastasorte ist.
SALLY: Auf einer Skala von…
JOSH: … von 1 bis 10 muss sie
6 oder höher sein.
Ergibt keinen Sinn, aber…
kommentiert halt mal, mein Gott!
Ich finde Fusilli cool.
Wollte ich nur sagen, falls das jemanden interessiert.
SALLY: Aber doch kein Fußfetisch, oder?
JOSH: Wer ist das?
[Alle lachen]
[Musik]